near this house at fourth and roof
there's an intersection i encountered it
every day for 20 years now I'm stood
there pushing the little crosswalk
signal button and after pushing it I
stand there and stand there and stand
there waiting for the light to change
the longer awake the more I push the
button over time I've tried variations
pushing it in a syncopated rhythm
pushing it at a certain amount of times
7 13 29 sometimes I thought it was
dependent on the time of day or season
or some complex citywide pattern known
to only a select few through doll for
four years now I stood there trusting in
some invisible traffic signal logic
until today today I brought a crowbar
and after i reamed it from the post i
unscrewed the plating back and I looked
inside nothing not a single wire just a
lone button attached to nothing but the
finger of a stupid pedestrian filled
with hope and trust I thought you should
know this and I take great pleasure and
when I'm about to say I do it all the
years all the times I stood out there
and push that button until my finger
aight i knew it we demand the illusion
of involvement just give us a button
that's all we ask because as long as we
have a button to push we assume that
we're making things happen but the truth
is the light changes when I wants to
we have nothing to do with
I'm not the kind of guy that spends hung
it on a last-minute flight to New York
tears across town and runs up six
flights of stairs to knock on my best
friends girlfriends door in order to run
off and elope with her based on one
crazy thoughtless inexplicably romantic
so what am I doing here Audrey I'm not
passionate I'm a fact checker for
Christ's sake soul mates how can I be
yours you barely know me and I barely
know you not your boyfriend I've known
him since kindergarten to throw all of
these years of friendship away based on
what some feeling that says I must be
with you or I'll die that only happens
in the movies but we're not in the mood
we are on MacDougal Street two blocks
south of Bleecker that's where we are
that is an indisputable geographical
fact and all the facts are pointing to
one thing we cannot do this because the
fact is you're in a relationship because
the fact is I just met you yesterday
because the fact is I'm not the kind of
man that falls in love that's a fact let
you see the problem the problem is
despite every fact I can muster I still
love you madly and it just defies all
reason
but I love you madly and I don't want
get help finally the day of reckoning
had come Robert Baratheon marched on the
city after his victory at trident but my
father got there first with the entire
Lannister army at his back promising to
defend the city against the rebels but I
knew my father better than that he was
never one to choose the losing side I
told the Mad King that much I urged him
to surrender peacefully but he didn't
listen to me and he didn't listen to
Varys who tried to warn him but he did
listen to grand maester pycelle that
grey sunken you can trust the
Lannisters he said the Lannisters have
always been friends of the crown so we
opened the gates and my father sacked
the city
once again I came to the king I pleaded
with him to surrender he told me to
bring him my father's head then he
turned to his Pyromancer and the mall he
said banned them all in their homes and
the mall in their beds tell me if your
precious Renly had commanded you to kill
your father and then stand by as
thousands of men women and children
burned alive would you have done it
would you have kept your oath then first
I killed the Pyromancer and then as a
King turned to flee I drove my sword
into his back burn them all he kept
saying burn them all I don't think he
expected to die I think he meant to burn
with the rest of us and rise again
reborn a dragon to turned his enemies
into ash and that's when I slit his
throat
to make sure that didn't happen and
that's when that stock found me
now is the winter of our discontent made
glorious summer by this son of York and
all the clouds allowed on a house in the
deep bosom of the ocean laid bare it now
our brows bound with victorious wreaths
our Stern alarums changed to merry
meetings our bruised arms hung up for
monuments win visit war has smooth it's
wrinkled front and now instead of
mounting barbed steeds to Fright the
souls of fearful adversaries he capers
nimbly in a lady's chamber to the
lascivious pleasing zuv a newt
but I then I'm not shaped for sportive
tricks nor made to court an amorous
looking-glass I that I am so rudely
stepped and want loves Majesty to strut
the forum unto mumbling nymph I am
curtailed of this fair proportion
cheated of feature by dissembling nature
deformed
I'm finished
sent before my time into this breathing
world scarce half made up and that's so
lamely and unfashionable that even the
dogs bark at me as I hope by them why I
in this weak piping time of peace have
no delight in person at a time Western
spy my own shadow in the Sun and that's
count on my own deformity therefore
since I cannot prove a lover to
entertain these fair well-spoken days I
am determined to prove a villain and
hate the idle pleasures of these days
can you can you wipe out that much red
Dre coughs daughter saw Paula the
hospital fire hoe Barton told me
everything you will ledger he's dripping
it's gushing red and you think saving a
man no more virtuous and yourself will
change anything this is the basest
sentimentality this is this is a child
at prayer Oh pathetic you lying killing
the service of liars and killers you
pretend to be separate to have your own
code something that will make up for the
Horus well they're a part of you and
they will never go away I went touch
button no not until I make him kill you
slowly intimately in every way he knows
you fear and then he'll wake up you wake
up just long enough to see his good work
and when he screams I'll split a skull
this is my bargain you mewling quim your
monster Oh No you brought the monster
I was thinking about a story from the
Bible I'm not a religious man but I've
read bits and pieces over the years
curiosity more than faith in this one
story there was a man he was traveling
from Jericho to Jerusalem when he was
set upon by men of ill intent they
stripped the traveler of his clothes
that beat him and they left him bleeding
in the dirt a priest happened by saw the
traveler crossed to the other side of
the road and continued on next day Lev
aight a religious functionary came to
the place saw the dying traveler but he
to cross to the other side of the road
and passed him by but then came a man
from Samaria a Samaritan a good man he
saw the traveler bleeding in the road
and stopped to eat him without thinking
about the circumstances or the
difficulty it might bring him he tended
to the travelers wounds applying oil and
wine he carried him to an inn and gave
him all the money he had for the manager
to take care of the traveler
he did this simply because the man was
his neighbor he loved his city and all
the people in it I always thought I was
the Samaritan in that story hmm it's
funny isn't it hell even the best of men
are deceived by their own true nature I
am NOT the Samaritan I am NOT the priest
or the or the leb aight i am the ill
intent who sit upon the traveler on a
road he should not have been on
ladies and gentlemen of the jury mr.
Paulsen has told you that the testimony
of Sirte bias is nothing sorry bias was
raped but that's nothing she was cut
bruised terrorized and that is nothing
all of it happened in front of a howling
crowd and that's nothing well it may be
nothing to mr. Paulsen but it is not
nothing to Sarah Tobias and I don't
believe that it is nothing to you next
mr. Paulsen tried to convince you but
Kenneth Joyce was the only person in
that room who knew that Sarah Tobias was
being raped the only one now you saw
cath chase how did he strike you did he
seem especially sensitive especially
observant did he seem so remarkable that
you immediately said to yourselves of
course this man would notice things that
other people wouldn't do you believe
that Kenneth Joyce saw something but
those three men didn't see the whole
time that Sarah Tobias was being held
down on that pinball machine the others
didn't know Kenneth Joyce confess to you
that he watched a rape and did nothing
he told you everyone in that bar behave
badly he was right but no matter how
immoral if maybe it is not the crime of
criminal solicitation to walk away from
a rape it is not the crime of criminal
solicitation to silently watch a rape
but it is the crime of criminal
solicitation to induce to encourage to
entreat to persuade another person to
commit a rape hold her down
stick it to her make her moan these
three men did worse than nothing they
cheered and they clapped and they routed
the others on made sure Sarah Tobias was
raped and raped and right now tell me is
that nothing
you